a fossil skull unearthed in 1996 has
puzzled researchers for decades
they refer to the animal it came from as
strange beast
in the desert of shenzhen china strange
beast is just one of a myriad of fossils
that have been uncovered
painting a picture of the diverse group
of animals that thrived over 14 million
years ago
now a study in science reconstructs what
this strange beast looked like
and how it fit in with neighboring
herbivores
first the researchers started by taking
ct scans of the specimen skull
they found that the outer wall of its
inner ear was very similar to giraffoids
a family of animals with only two living
species
back in the miocene many other kinds of
giraffoids prospered sporting a variety
of bony structures affixed atop their
heads
but the strange beast's headgear stood
out
no antlers here instead it dawned a
thick flat layer of bone
up close the bone was rough suggesting a
tough outer layer coated this bony top
likely made of keratin
the researchers named this animal disco
carrick's cheshire disco carricks
meaning round-plated horn and she
a reference to a single horned beast
from chinese legends
moving down from the skull to the neck
more unusual features appeared
its vertebrae were extremely thick
containing large areas where the joints
touch each other between vertebrae
to see if this sturdily built neck and
durable headgear could have been useful
for combat the researchers analyzed
churches vertebrae to see how much
stress it could withstand
after running simulations of head
butting with and without this extra
overlap they found that the thicker
vertebrae better absorbed the blow of
intense combat and prevented the head
from rotating too far simulations also
revealed that the disc shaped headgear
better protected the brain than the
horns of sheep and musk oxen
next the researchers analyzed isotopes
and checha's tooth enamel to understand
where they lived and foraged
plants animals eat contain different
amounts of carbon 13
while oxygen 18 varies depending on an
animal's source of water
the high average value of carbon 13
suggests that cherche foraged on open
land unlike other herbivores in the
community which stuck to forests
the large range of oxygen 18 values
could mean that she drank water from
multiple sources
or changed where they live depending on
the season
together these isotope findings suggest
that shercha had a distinct range from
other herbivores in the community
giraffoids particularly today's
extremely long neck giraffes have often
been used as a lesson by those
interested in how animals evolve traits
darwin proposed that their elongated
necks evolved from competition with
other browsers
others think that the long necks formed
from necking among males struggling for
dominance
both environment and combat could have
played a role in how the strange beast
got its hat
shercha fed from a different part of the
ecosystem than other herbivores
comparable to the unique area giraffes
browse for food
competition for resources among checho's
males might have led to combat and the
evolution of strongly reinforced heads
and burly necks
who knows what type of wacky headgear
researchers may unearth in the future